[Music]
[Music]
well as you know this is the second
webinar on how to extract data from the
web this is part two of the series and
I'll cover web scraping if you missed
the last webinar in November ninth at
that one we looked at how to gather data
off the web that's provided through an
API and that webinar has been recorded
and it's already available at WRC comm
/resources Leslie slash webinars the
same place that this webinar will end up
itself if you'd like to review it API so
you could go there watch that webinar
what we'll cover today is how to scrape
data off a web page so this is data that
exists in the web page but isn't
necessarily easy to access and certainly
hasn't been prepackaged in the API as
with the previous webinar this will be
an introductory level webinar so I'll
cover some basic ideas behind web
scraping I'll review as quickly as I can
the important points of HTML and CSS I
would go to rely on I'm going to
introduce an r package design to make it
easier to scrape data off the web name
to our vest and I'll cover a tool called
selector gadget that works very well
with web scraping together these tools
form a basic set of tools that you can
use to collect data off almost any
webpage that you you can imagine
especially basic web pages so they're
very useful but they are somewhat simple
if you already are familiar with HTML
and CSS we've even done web scraping
already and you just want to learn more
about the are best package you might be
able to save time by simply going to the
Arve selector gadget vignette which is
at this address you could read that
about five minutes and skip over all the
review that I'm going to do now this
vignette is not as comprehensive as the
vignette I suggested for the HTT our
package in the last webinar however I
think there's enough information there
that you can really get a quick overview
of the topic and get started right away
the last thing I want to say before we
begin is that just like with the last
webinar this material is derived from a
workshop that I co-taught with Scott
Chamberlin and Karthik Graham had to
last use our conference and if you'd
like to see there
original workshop materials they're
available at this gear repository
alright so let's talk about web scraping
and let's put it in context we learned
in the last webinar that many web sites
that provide data provided through an
API which is just a systematic way for a
piece of software to interact with that
website to collect the data if your data
is available through an API you're in
luck because it's very easy to write
code that accesses the API and gets the
data in an automated way maybe I just
don't just exist for the web you've also
probably run into them in databases
operating systems software packages and
so on and one example of a Web API that
we looked at in the last webinar was the
OM DB API which was a database of
information related to movies that is
provided through an API so they're easy
to access today we're going to look at a
similar webpage but a very different web
page that is IMDB stands for the
International Movie Database and it
provides the same type of information
you have information about movies such
as who was starring in which movie what
rating did the movie gave what year they
come out and so on so there's all sorts
of useful information there but IMDB
does not provide it through an API IMDB
I'm just inferring here but I think they
want to pull you to the webpage put your
eyeballs on the page so they can then
expose you to what looks like a large
amount of ads which maybe they make the
revenue from now in this situation if I
were trying to actually collect movies
dated I would first check and see if
there was an API which would make my
life easier and in this case there is so
I would use it but I'm going to use the
IMDB site here as a convenient example
of how to scrape web data and the way
we're gonna try on the nature of web
pages so just to quickly review how web
pages work every website that you visit
is stored as a set of instructions on a
web server server somewhere you visit it
through a web browser on your computer
and the first thing that happens when
you try to access that website is your
computer so it's a request on the server
that hosts the website when the server
gets that request normally sends back
in a HTML document that contains all the
instructions that your web browser needs
to build the web page you're trying to
visit once your web browser has that
document then it uses those instructions
to put together the web page then you
see it there on your computer then from
that point various exchanges can happen
in things occur but this is the basics
of every web page if you were to look at
the HTML document that your web browser
receives it's just text text
instructions it's format in a particular
way but everything that appears on that
web page will be mentioned somewhere
here in the instructions and this is the
kernel of our strategy for web scraping
if we were to go to IMDB here here's the
web page and real life let's say we
wanted to look at the cast of this movie
so IMDB displays the cast very
prominently in this table here we see
the star was Kristen Bell Idina Menzel
and so on if we wanted to get that
information we can certainly come here
and look at it and write it down
ourselves but that's not an efficient at
all instead we could look at the HTML
source for the web page now chrome makes
it very easy to look at the source for a
web page you don't need to do this to
scrape data but I just want to show you
what it looks like
here's the source for that web page it's
quite complicated let's you know if we
were trying to find Kristen Bell we
should be able to use our search feature
and we see that you know every mention
of her in the web page is also somewhere
here in in this text we just have to
find it and extract so if we want to
find Kristen Bell and this web page our
ending actor in the web page we just
need to find the source and extract it
from the correct location in the source
that's going to be our basic strategy
for web scraping we're pulling things
out of the source of the web page now
you can look at that source and it
probably occurred to you that that's
just one giant character string and you
could use regular expressions of
character string manipulations to
extract pieces of that and I'm proud too
you feel comfortable doing that but
that's not a very efficient way to go
about strapping information from HTML
document because hTML is meant to have a
structure it's based around a structured
and if you understand that structure you
can extract information from the
document in a more precise and targeted
way now if there are any beginners out
there seeing HTML now I'm starting to
get afraid don't worry by the end of
this webinar you'll see that you don't
have to touch the HTML we'll use our
tools to do that
but it is important to have at least
some idea of what context this web
scraping activity is occurring it so
let's look at the structure of HTML very
quickly HTML organizes content by
placing tags around the content here's
an example tag this piece of HTML would
create a link to github.com and the link
would appear in a document as just the
word get out and if you open this in a
web browser that word impliedly Ballou
or something so you know that there's a
link and you could click on the tag here
in this piece of code is a it stands for
anchor it's it's for web links and the
tag has a name and it starts right after
you know the less than sign this tag
also has an attribute in this case the
attribute is named href and that
attribute has a value and the value is
in this case the name of the website we
want to link to and then github itself
is the content of the tag when you're
scraping data you could scrape any of
these things out of these chanel but
most often you'll want the actual
content that's in your web page or in
the HTML if we looked at that sample
HTML that I put up on the screen a few
moments ago it's legitimate HTML this is
not the actual HTML fry MDB we saw that
was much more verbose and complex but we
can use this HTML get a sense of how
these tags are organized within any web
page the tags are organized in a
hierarchy so this web page here begins
with an HTML tag and then the next level
of a hierarchy is a head tag and a body
tag which sort of divides the web page
of the two so we could visualize this as
a tree under the head tag we have some
other tags title links scripts and under
the body tag Bassem tags and then those
tags also have their own sub tags for
example if P and span here and beneath P
we have a B tag and then we have some
tables with their own items now if you
wanted to find a piece of content in
this simple web page for example if you
want to find the word here
we need to know is that it occurs inside
the be tag and the B tags in this
location and then you could search for
that B tag and extract this content and
you'd have the word here so this is sort
of what we're going to do when we scrape
data out of our web pages so if we want
to find Kristen Bell's name she's the
lead actress here we would need to
figure out which HTML tags surrounds her
name and the code so in this case inside
the source code up I will I'll search
for a name and you know I found it here
you know she's the star of the show so
her name is mentioned in several places
but I'm most interested in this piece
here because if I can extract Kristen
Bell in this table I should be able
extract every other actor actress on the
table so we're looking at the cast table
no bar I searched through this web page
a little bit and you can see here's cast
so this is the table and here's Kristen
doll this is referring to her picture
she appears on table here's her actual
name in the table and we can see that
it's contained in the span tag so we
know which which tag surrounds Kristen
Bell but in this particular web page
there are many many span tags are not
just used for Kristen Bell's name in
fact if we were to search the web page
we'd see that it was about 600 span tags
so we're off to a good start narrowing
in on the content we want to get but
we're not narrow enough we don't want to
pull out 600 values and then have to
search through those manually to get
Kristen Bell and just as a reminder the
reason we're doing all this stuff trying
to find these tags and and understand
the structure and how our information is
embedded in because at the end of the
day we want to largely automate this
process we don't want to do things
manually we want to have our computer
save us time by doing it for us let's
look at how we could zoom in or be a
little more targeted when we search for
Kristen Bell it really needs more than
just the HTML tag to describe and locate
her name in this document we're going to
do that by taking advantage of another
technology that's the use with web pages
and that's CSS so if you're not familiar
with CSS here's a very brief
introduction if you have an HTML
document with those tags are you looking
at you'll be able to create a page that
has text and links and paragraphs and
stuff but
gonna look very plain because HTML
doesn't really contain all that much I
mean I think there's like a hundred tags
you can use but they're all very basic
so if you can say what page you might
visited like SHINee are you calm if you
look just at the HTML the webpage it
would build something that looks like
this a plain white document and if
you've ever tried to load a web page
with a really slow connection you may
have actually seen a web page that look
like this your computer is just trying
to help you out and show you what it can
before the rest of the information
relates web page showed up that
information would be CSS you combine CSS
with an HTML document you get a styled
web page so this is how the shining that
are stood on my page looks if you visit
it and you'll notice it has the same
components it has the same text and the
same web sites and stuff but they all
look different they have a different
style and is that style that really
makes the visual experience that you
want to have when you visit the web page
we understand how CSS works we can use
it to scrape data as well as you know
style web pages so if you look at an
example CSS file you'd see something
that looks a little bit like this these
are sets of instructions between the
brackets here we have actual pieces of
styling so color : ffffff
that's choosing a specific color for
something to be and then we're choosing
a width lower down when choosing a
background color
we're down this is styling the other
part of the CSS the part that will rely
on our selectors so where it says span
or dot no more table dot data this tells
your web browser which parts of the HTML
document to apply the styling to for
example that color ffffff that's only
going to be applied to span tags we've
already seen some span tag so any span
tag in that hypothetical webpage will
have a certain color and then we'll see
what that nom de scribes in the table
that data describes but these selectors
are a way to specify specific elements
in the web page to then apply styling to
but this idea of specifying a specific
element in web page is how you're going
Strack specific elements as data we're
going use the same system so let's look
at the basics of the system here is an
HTML tag it's a span tag
notice this tag has a class
an ID attribute that has some consonant
content here says shiny
there's our class here's our ID you know
it because that's the names and then
here's a selector that we could use in
CSS to describe this tag the word span
and the selector will refer to every
span tag that exists in your HTML
document and since this is the span tag
you'll refer to this as well so any
styling we group under the span tag will
be applied here but we could also be
more specific in the way we apply our
styling we could apply ursine based on
class so the span tag has a class big
name if you want to create a CSS
selector that says find all the elements
who have the class big name we do that
by putting a period and then big name so
that period prefix tells your web
browser that this selector is a class
selector it matches everything that has
the class big name and if we put that
career together with span now we're
saying we want to match everything that
is both a span element and a big name
class so it's even more specific and
then we could also be very very precise
and if we set an ID name for a tag then
we can refer to that tag by its ID with
the hash tag so hash tags shiny would
refer to anything that has an ID shiny
but normally when you're writing web
page only one thing about that ID so
those selectors we saw there refer to
different things and the way they refer
to them is with the prefix that is put
in front of them the perfects is that
you could use our know prefix which
refers to the tag name a dot which
refers to the class name and a hash of
it refers to an ID now will there be a
quiz on this later yeah kind of you
don't actually need to remember all this
I'm gonna show you a tool that does it
for you but you will need to be familiar
with this if you want to understand
what's going on all right so which CSS
end identifiers are associated with
Kristen Bell's name well if we go back
over here we see it's a span it has the
class item prop and item props just
another attribute so we're looking at
span and class item problem so that
should narrow things down a little bit
for us
in fact I do a search for the
and see now there's 32 elements that
have this combination and since we're
looking at a whole table with names the
next elements here its next label on the
table that might be okay I mean we're
trying to at the end of the day collect
every name in that table so this might
help us get there all right okay so this
is our strategy we go extract
information from the HTML document that
underlies the web page and we're going
to use in structured HTML as well as CSS
to find that's precise information well
this is a webinar and now we're finally
going to get to an R package and R code
that you can use with that knowledge II
just gained the package is called our
vest it's an R package that makes it
easy to extract and fruit from a web
page and you can install it straight
from cran with installed our packages
our vest this is also go install some
packages our vest depends on
particularly XML to which some of the
functions I'll be using come from but
when you install our vest you get that
as well the basic workflow for working
with our vests is actually very simple
you can narrow it down to three
functions but maybe more depending on
your trying to find the first thing you
do is you download the HTML document for
a web page with the read the HTML
function then R will have all the
information that sent your web browser
but now it's inside R where you can
start to work on it the second thing you
do is you extract specific nodes with
HTML nodes so read hTML is going to turn
that HTML into XML which is just another
way to organize that information sort of
like when you save things in are you've
only save as a list
Alissa's way of organizing information
it's easier for our vests to use the XML
format in XML each tag is named it's
called a node and HTML knows will
extract the different nodes in your HTML
document and then finally once you have
the specific node you want like the span
node for example you can extract the
content of the node using one of these
helper functions or alternatively you
can extract the name span or the
attributes of the tags such as
class equals this and itemprop people
equals that you could also extract the
tags that are children of that tag and
tables in specific way so I'm gonna
cover all these things and I'm going to
do this in our studio with some real
code so here we go when we post this
webinar material there'll be two scripts
that come with it and the scripts are
already right here the first one is
called frozen dark and I'll cover the
second one when we get to it so this is
a script that uses Arvest functions to
extract data from IMDB if we go realign
those functions we need to first load
library our vests which loads the
package our best and then the name of
the website that we were looking at the
website for frozen is right here this is
the URL if I want to read that into our
I will use the read HTML function and I
will give it the URL so this is actually
very simple you just read in the URL I'm
going to save that to an object named
frozen now if I were to look at frozen
you can see it has its own print method
it's it's an XML document and here we
see you know it's an HTML document and
that has a head node in a body node this
should looks familiar
and beneath each of those are other
nodes and what we're looking at is the
top of the HTML tree for this document
now we figured out that we wanted to
extract everything that had the CSS
selector spandau itemprop these are all
the tags or nodes if you will that are
spans and have the itemprop class the
way we're going to extract those is with
HTML nodes function from RFS we're go
give it the webpage which I saved up
here frozen we're going to tell it which
CSS selector used to extract nodes
here's our CSS selector I'm going to
save all those nodes it's cast the cast
is what I'm trying to get to
I look at cast I could see here we have
a many HTML tags or XML nodes
they're all span they're all class
itemprop and they all contain a little
bit of content down here we see Kristen
Bell we see I denim Iselle and jonathan
groff these are the actors and actresses
of frozen however we do also see some
things here like animation adventure
clearly these aren't actors and
actresses and if we're just trying to
select all the names and the table for
this
and another movie in any movie on this
webpage you probably want to do a little
more work to make sure we're not
extracting things like adventure and
animation I'll come back to that in a
second well let's finish this third step
here I've extracted these notes as cats
if I want to get to the content of the
note if I want to drop all the span
class item prop which a problem do I can
use HTML text to extract the content of
the node as text so HTML text cast now
gives me the content each of those nodes
and in here is the list of all the
actors and actresses for this movie
along with some extra stuff that we're
going to have to filter out if I want
just the name of each of these notes I
could get that they're all span that's
kind of determined because I use the
span CSS selector up here but this is
how you get the names if I don't want
that attributes reach these tags and get
the attributes for each tag and here we
see some information that might help us
narrow things down
many of these are class item prop and
then they have a name value for item
prop which is now being used as an
attribute but some of the other ones are
class on proper than having genre value
or further down below we saw keyword
value now I'm pretty sure in genre these
ones of the genre value where things
like action and adventure which we
probably want dropped in keywords
probably have something other than an
actor and actresses name so this is a
way we can start to differentiate then
finally if we want to see if there were
children tags or nodes for these things
that we've extracted we can use HTML
children in this case there aren't any
children
each of these things contains a name but
it doesn't contain further attributes to
explore so just read
load HTML with read HTML the function
relational just takes URL the web page 1
in download if you're connected to the
internet this is the value RL R will go
fetch stage Gmail for that web page next
we extracted specific nodes at the HTML
nodes you give HTML nodes the names of
the website that you downloaded the
object you saved it to that is and then
a CSS selector that helps it select
specific nodes from that web page we
finally use one of these functions to
extract the Civic types of content from
all the nodes that you just collected we
did this and we got this list of content
while we scrape too much information
because we have things here beyond the
actors and actresses names and this is
pretty common when you are scraping data
from a web page before I come back and
fix that I want to show you how to use
HTML tables because oftentimes you're
trying to get data from a web page it's
appears in the web page as a table and
if that's the case and you can track
that whole table all together into a
data frame in R which is terribly
convenient so let's look at another
webpage that has some table information
this is best places net it's a website
run by Sperling's
and you can look up any city including
where you live and find out information
about your place of residence or a place
you're considering moving to so I pulled
up the web page for Orlando I live near
Orlando and Orlando is also the venue
for the upcoming our studio conference
so I thought this would be appropriate
and since the conference is January
maybe we should look at the weather in
Orlando and see what it's like
the average January low is 47 49 degrees
which actually is pretty low for around
here people could say that freezing it
doesn't really get that cool but you can
see that this climate information is
laid out in a table so let's try to
extract this whole table at once into a
data frame and I've written a script
that can help us do that recall this is
the URL if the page that has the table
you go to best places are the other
script it's three steps it's running off
the page but here's our URL so the first
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
read that URL in and save it as Orlando
next I'm going
look for any nodes that have the CSS
class table so anything that's a table I
want to extract I'm gonna extracted two
tables using our HTML notes function to
do that
I look at tables you see I got some
tables in here and then finally I'm
going to use the HTML table function to
extract the tables if I extract all
these tables we have four tables here
we're all get it's a list for tables in
it and you can see that some of the text
in that web page was organized as a
table so for example condo view this is
you know a table even though it might
not look like that this is pretty common
because an HTML tables are a way to
orient things on the page even if you
don't think them as data tables but the
second table we collected actually is a
data table and I could drill down into
that using you know this subset notation
so HTML table - now is this table and
this table is a data frame that's how
easy was to read that data into our as a
data frame so now I could say that to
its own object and start working with it
to do whatever I want and this code here
worked for any Spurling web page just
that's organized in the same way so I
can create a for loop or use map and
change the URL each time I run this code
but doing the same thing to extract
these tables for every location I'm
interested in NASA power of web scraping
the automation okay so that was a short
aside about tables but let's come back
to our problem of we haven't really
found the best way to collect actor and
actresses names from IMDB the way we're
going to solve this problem is with a
tool called selector gadget selector
gadget is an actual tool that you
download to your web browser and you use
it to zero in on specific parts of a web
page it adds an overlay to your web page
it looks like this and you use it in a
way that's gooey so I'll just show you
how to use it the best way to acquire
this tool is to open our and run
vignette selector gadget that's the
vignette for our vests that I suggested
people read earlier if we do that
now you'll want to have our vests loaded
when you do this because the vignette
comes in the harvest package sorry I
think it's not cactus you get this
selector gadget vignette and right here
at the top it says to install select
your gadget open this page in your
browser then drag the following link to
your bookmark bar so you know I know
this works for Google Chrome I imagine
there's some browsers out there that you
might have trouble with but Google
Chrome is free so you can always get
Google Chrome and then you take select
your gadget you drop into your bookmarks
bar just so happens already have to hear
it because I prepped for this webinar
let's go to the frozen IMD web page and
the way we would you select your gadget
is when we're on the web page we'd open
this bookmark you load select your
gadgets like your gadgets now at the
bottom of the page you could see and now
when I hover over different elements in
the page do that they change colors if I
wanted to extract a piece information
from the web page I click on that
information so here I want to find every
actor and actresses name and I'm using
Kristen Bell's my test case so I'll
click on Kristen Bell and what selector
gadget does is it tries to find the CSS
that describes that name and then it
highlights everything in the web page
that uses the same CSS so if I want all
the actors and actresses this looks
pretty good I'm able to get them all but
I also see other things are highlighted
down here and these are the things I
don't want so the first step is to
highlight what you want and then you
just start trimming it back
snowman's highlighted and I don't want
snowman so I'll click that selector
gadget will come up with a way to still
collect what I click before but not
collect this so now it's suggesting this
CSS selector and then if I wanted
something else in this case I don't I
think I've narrowed it down but if I
also want to collect you know these then
I could click on you know what I want
cut - and then you know modify it so
basically you just click click highlight
things you don't want to get rid of them
click things that are I laid that you do
want to add them
and select your gadget will come up with
a CSS path for you to use so this path
looks pretty good so I'm going to take
that I'll come back to my script here
now I already have frozen downloaded but
I can use this new CSS because there's
something different other use this new
CSS to collect a more specific set of
nodes I'll save these as cast two and if
we look at the text inside of cast two
we can see now it really is just the
actor and actresses names and when it
gets to this point there's no correct
CSS to use oftentimes you get the same
thing in multiple ways so maybe based on
how you click things like a gadget gives
you this path you know and it provides
the same information and one thing that
you might want to keep in mind is if you
do this activity one day and you come
back six months later and you want to
redo it
websites do change from the CSS that you
want to use might itself change as well
I recommend in every case that you
select your gadget to quickly zero in on
CSS path that gets you what you want now
if you use this you don't even need to
know how to write CSS but it can be
helpful to look at what selector gadgets
giving you and try to figure out what
this is saying
so here's things with the ID title cast
and the class item prom another way
tunes
your gadget is to just go to select your
gadget calm that webpage talks about
such a gadget more from an are agnostic
perspective just a new selector gadget
to stay CSS and you can download from
there as well this is sort of you know
what I did in action I don't actually
think reading this list is helpful but
it's in the slides and they'll be in the
slides when you download these materials
so there are other things in the
selector gadget tool that you can use
and probably the most useful one is
clear if you just want to start over you
can click the Clear button and then
start clicking again from scratch and
then if your gadget is actually in the
way of the thing that you want to
highlight you can click the toggle
position button which will put the
gadget somewhere else on the page so you
can get access to the thing you want to
click and then there's help and you can
close the Quechan so on all right
so let's recap when you're scraping data
from the web the strategy that you're
going to use is you're going to pull the
data right out of the HTML that the
webpage is contained in and you're going
to rely on the HTML CSS structure of
that web page to refer to the data that
you want
since HTML and CSS structure is uniform
across web pages within a site you can
use that structure to automate the
retrieval of data across that site the
Arvest package lets you enact this
strategy you download the data using
real HTML this collects the entire
website you didn't pull out just the
tags that you want using HTML nodes and
CSS selectors you can use the selector
gadget to get those selectors but now
I'm getting ahead of myself finally once
you have the nodes you extract the
content with the helper function which
is normally HTML text if your node is a
table you can extract the whole table as
a heart friendly data frame with HTML
table and then you can use the selector
gadget widget to find useful selector
combinations to get just the information
that you want this is the best way to go
about it because there's not necessarily
gonna be much rhyme or reason or
intuition to follow about which CSS
selectors best describe what you want so
thank you very much
for that introduction or web scraping we
have some time so I'll try to answer
some questions just give me a second to
pull up those questions how will our
vests handle badly form pages or missing
ending tags I think our vests can handle
missing ending tags fairly well but our
vest does expect some cooperation with
the page designer and it's relying on
the structure of the web page and if the
person rotating I'll really screw that
up then expect surprises and trouble
with our vest and unfortunately I can't
really think of what what we can do to
minimize that what if the web page is
accessed through a username password
that's a great question with Travis why
yes you can access such web pages with
our vest and best way to get into that
would I be if you look at the web page
read HTML I guess I'd you can do that I
was hoping that the the help page for
read HTML would cover this but it's not
there so let me try to figure out which
help page would have that basically you
just need to include extra arguments
that include your password and username
regarding changing site structures do
you have recommendations or best
practices for future proofing production
scripts that rely on scrape data well in
this case I don't I have seen web pages
change and change fast especially if you
are working with with a webpage that
you're coming back to because the data
is being updated on a regular basis if
you're relying on CSS selectors or the
structure of the web page those things
may change the best practice for doing
this is to once your script and scrape
the data to check that data to make sure
it's what you expected to get at least
that's the right type or it's not error
or dollar na and then if if the data is
not what you expected then you'll have
to reason error if the web page has
changed you can't predict how let's go
change necessarily so the best you could
do is notice that's change then go back
and fix the process
which packages are required again just
the are vest package that's RV EST and
it sounds like harvest that does load
some other packages that XML too but all
you need to install harvest what are the
legal issues with scraping we're dead
yes Danny well I'm glad you brought that
up more debt I
it's very ambiguous so I cannot provide
legal advice on this topic can use
Arvest with HTTP I yes and I think that
you might get into the authentication
stuff after you visit two functions like
HTML notes return data as lists nice to
find HTML nodes returns data as a
specific s3 object so here Cass was in
HTML was HTML nodes and you can see it's
an XML node set of 32 and you use these
helper functions to extract that into a
more friendly format so once we did HTML
text on cast then we just have a text
vector but what HTML nodes returns is
something that is a slightly exotic
object but it's easier to work with the
XML data that's stored in it using that
s3 class however the class is based on
the list so it doesn't Herot some less
methods we're the best techniques to
navigate through a number of webpages ie
to click Next by Robert Allen Robert the
HTT our package which we used in the
previous webinar addresses this a little
better than the our best package it
includes here's all the L pages in the
package but it includes some a CTR is
probably where the off comes from I uh
it includes some functions that do help
you navigate web pages I'm not sure if
these are still experimental or not I
don't use them and I don't see him so
maybe they were experiments but you know
for example you can use browse
I think some others so once again I'm at
the extent of my knowledge but explore
the HTT our package for that it's not
really an hour vest feature but you can
slowly combine the two the two web pages
also if you study the URL for the web
pages that you're using you can often
discover the structure or the
organization of the webpage and then you
can create the URLs yourself I guess
that's not foolproof but it it is
something I kind of hack around doing
all right how would you expect the same
type of information across multiple
pages for example if I won the cast for
all Disney movies from 2015 2005 to 2015
once you figure out how to extract the
data from one web page you can use that
same sequence of functions extracted
from every web page that has the same
structure every web page on the same
site should have the same structure you
just need to supply the URL for each of
those web pages in into your script so
if you can get those URLs and you can
use a for loop to automate everything
that follows how you come up with those
URLs depends on the web page if you can
figure out the HTTP are or the automated
way to navigate through links on web
pages which I wish I didn't explain very
well at all and I apologize then perhaps
you could use that on the other hand it
might be easier to just study the
structure of the URLs and change the
names that's in the URL if that's how it
works but you will need those and put
URLs and you need to figure out a way to
get them somehow after you do that
everything else you can automate with
the three-step sequence we covered can
you extract data points from a graph on
the website by James Brophy James I do
not think so I'm not optimistic about
that at all because most graphs are just
go be images on the webpage and I think
we have time for one more question so
I'll choose one that I can actually
answer that might be a little more
satisfying but a patch floss s is there
a way to get specific item prop value eg
genre from our list
and this is this is important you can
see we download these things and here
one of the attributes of the tags is
itemprop with your data might be
something else of relevance and you
might want to get this value instead of
the content of the actual tag and the
way you could do that is with HTML
attributes or attrs
so when I run that on cast here I do get
a list and it's a free each of the nodes
in that list I get the itemprop value
and it's named the name of that values
item problem so this is how you would
extract that all right thank you all
very much for attending the webinar
[Music]